[Music]
[Music]
therapy it's been a hot minute since
we've done logo therapy so I'm super
excited to do local therapy with you and
we have a brand new therapist on the
show today
it's Mart and Everton he's gonna fill
the big shoes that Davi has left behind
but I think I was the right person for
the job if you're new to the show in the
format to the channel will welcome
beautiful people we're gonna be doing
two logos from two designers today 2x2
is what we call this with Mart's and
Everton first up is going to be Mart
if you don't know who he is you can
check him out on Instagram and studio op
Mars he's from the Netherlands and it's
a massive heat wave going on right he's
trying to stay cool but looking good
well while he's doing it this is some of
his work really neat work nice nice work
here and brand-new to the show we've
been trying to find him a dance partner
I couldn't find him one and then the
opportunity opened up and so here he is
all the way from Campo Grande Brazil is
Everton Everton this is his work look
how fresh this work is hey Jonah will
you stop doing that Hey I've been told
by the team I need to mention this as
some of you guys don't know this but we
actually sell courses on designed and
logos and you might want to check them
out so that's all I'm gonna say about
that just to let you guys know
so first up you picked a guy named
Daniel young and he did something called
or for Brooks flooring so some kind of
lumber flooring thing now I'm going to
turn it over to you take it away my
friend all right so I've got a finest
video of the process okay and you can
talk about it oh yeah I just saw your
first I made some notes of myself when I
was going to change and what I think
could be a proof so first of all the
typography was traced a bit with next to
the side and also on the bottom so that
was the first thing I was changed
next to the symbol and then I start just
sketching like creating my own version
of his symbol and working on proportions
because it's felt a bit like it was
stretched and wash it felt a bit off so
I was just redoing his logo basically
and then after a while give it my own
little twist I guess mm-hmm so I'm just
this your style of work just open up
Photoshop get create some sketches so
here I got the idea maybe adding to be
inside the yeah like the initials of the
company later on you'll see that I also
tried to put the D F on the floor
because it's a Florida company so yeah
I'm just creating a really basic grid to
help me create get the right proportions
and just clean up discussion on it quick
before us so basically I'm just copying
and pasting everything I'm doing
constantly just to be able to like go
some steps back if it's needed and also
have like some back-up plan in case you
did something wrong or in case you want
to chase something I think it's easy to
constantly just keep copying and pasting
your work so that you can always undo
your mistakes did you draw a vanishing
point are you free handing that no
basically the vanishing point artistry
is 2.0 but I'm free I think most of this
mm-hmm
I'm using the the lines of red lines
basically as guidelines I think so this
is where I so you're just trying out
things maybe a black background or I'm
also creating a version with like just
the border are used to the bar going but
my final logo that I actually created
it's far different from this so it's
completely different
the other thing is always when I'm
creating and quitting like these designs
and just one I'm working constantly like
I like you know ideas popping into my
head right I also when I'm putting on
Pinterest or the ants or whatever I see
something that inspires me sometimes I
just start over it's different right
so the next step here was I had this
random idea of trying a different
perspective because perspective on that
one develop it's forced to meet fellow
bits I don't know what's very suitable
for logo so why don't you create
something a bit cleaner so yeah I'm just
basically using this geometric shape to
use that as a foundation for mm-hmm
but it's not even the final one yet I
constantly kept changing the direction I
was taking but yeah here's a bit more
clear at the office actually on the
floor yeah and this is with like more
isometric perspective right yeah so
restore the bits most suitable for low
very low
mm-hmm because you want to be able to
read it on the old small skills well and
I think the one on the Left which goes
down goes a bit unreadable so this was
actually the direction that I ended up
you see I saw a picture on the internet
of like I don't I don't know if it was
some bogus what else but of the width of
the floor curling up a bit so I thought
it was pretty cool to have like this
curling effect whether it be is actually
like the shadow of the of the earth oh
so that's just a couple of variation
that's the idea and I think somewhere
between working on this I also went back
to the other idea try to have another
thing here but I didn't been abusing
this something really liked it so it is
like constant back and forth of you
having like new ideas men or make this
this will work on the old idea and back
again I know exactly what you mean when
you're working it's like you're your
hands can't move as fast as you're Ryan
you do this and you're like this and
then you just try to quickly get that
down and move on to the next one this is
where I think having proficiency in
tools is really important because you
can move at the speed of thought right
like look at how many different things
he's iterating on so he's not stuck on
one direction this is really critical so
when you're designing marks and symbols
it's important that you try as many
ideas as you think are valid worth
exploring not just because you're
limited by your skill set so I'm just
this we skeptics wall party because I
made this cache on another computer when
I wasn't but I basically same idea but
it's a bit more straightforward but I
didn't end up using it because it was a
bit boring and I also liked the
perspective of the one that bought this
because it gives more the impression of
a shouldn't be in the floor okay one is
your head which is so far is that it's
Brooks flooring right not flooring
Brooks so there you know that's I was
going to mention this I've actually
switched it around here like I read your
mind
there goes using the one about the
efforts becoming first because some
reason I just liked it more because the
F is a bit more hidden on the beat and
for me to be is more important but the s
more like hidden gimmick like it's not
something that you notice right away
decided to keep that way
but I knew this was going to be the
first feedback because this was also my
own mind like I didn't like because this
is my report lines probably if this was
like client projects I'm pretty sure the
client would have also pushed back on
this like we want to be to want to be to
be the first leather right but I was
like I'm just going to pick the one
about like most visually because it's
not much time in this case right why not
I mean it's you're doing this for fun
it's part of your explorations so do the
thing that you love yeah and also
because in this case like in the later
stages
I think the techniques that I'm using
are naturally people ask this question
all the time which is how long is it
taking you from start to this point
right now how much time in these bad I
think this was spots two or three hours
okay no I think you'd be shorter because
I think the whole process of from start
to finish was about three or four hours
like dropped into 15 min senior Wow
so here I'm using the shapes of the like
the gaps between death using it to build
the typography which is kinda spell the
name
because I was because I was pretty cool
in proportions as something that's
returns like they're the thickness of
the medicine the symbol also the same as
the thickness of the medicine obviously
mm-hmm this doesn't really quick just
quick scratch to get an idea of what it
might look like in length so this is
actually you still motion with the
letters turned around right I switch to
expect at the later point that's almost
like if I could just go mm-hmm just
Union let's train arrows in Photoshop
master in Photoshop I'm just if I in the
sketch at this point because it looks I
know what it's going to look like an
illustrator but I need to refine it the
bits who will be able to like funny said
compute faster you know administrator I
don't want to get stuck in industry so
I'm already planning a bit ahead here so
I'm not a proportions like the thickness
of the FB is twice the thickness off to
get off the B so I know that in my head
when I go in to illustrate it's usually
a bit great for guidelines a question
for you how did you learn and when did
you develop this technique of working
like this with quick sketching in
Photoshop and working on proportions and
things like that
well actually I used to do a lot of
illustration which the arts or the
drawing parts this comes natural to me
mm-hmm on the government so like
actually full-time branding since about
a year now two years maybe like
basically I used to work a lot for DJ's
and grades that cover odd works and then
they asked me like can you also do a
logo and I was like okay sure I'll just
do it without even know how to do this
so I kind of applied a lot of thickness
by
use while illustrating to my global
design process that makes sense
mhm so for me to drunk was actually the
easiest part and then they illustrate a
part of me is something that I'm still
learning about above and basically just
learning everyday in one so that makes a
lot of sense
with your background I should that's
that's why he can draw so fast right and
your drawings pretty tight yeah so most
of it is free ends and then get a
question about all your trophy yeah like
so clean but it's just by doing it above
practicing a lot mm-hmm and it also
helps to have a Wacom tablet or whatever
other tablets because you can easily go
back in time and just removing things or
going back in your history yeah
so that's why I'm very sketching on
Photoshop me next to sketching on paper
well I think that's also pretty personal
he's whatever works yeah so this is also
still polish up on you I'm just using
the geometric shapes like circles and
lines to make sure that's going to be
clean the ends you use use Photoshop
like the way I use illustrator you're
very organized with your files and
duplicating things it's sometimes I'm
working in Photoshop and I got three
layers and I can't undo anything it's
all destructive at this point yeah
that's exactly the reason why I always
duplicate the layers because I've made
so many mistakes in the past they
couldn't undo because only same layer so
I got used to always keeping a backup
now mm-hmm well I think the sketch is
almost finished mm-hmm sorry I'm just
quickly redoing the typography because
the proportions gets a little bit so as
you can see they're the thickness of the
the book of these the same size as it
gets up symbol mm-hmm I don't know why
it's just I'm like just might wouldn't
like this it's the only way you you're
hitting me like it gives me the rest in
my hand I should say right
I noticed something your vertical stroke
is thicker I mean your horizontal
strokes are thicker than your vertical
strokes no that's why because optically
I became all yours eyes right yeah
because if you look at it at least the
you know what maybe I take that back
because my screen is stretched right now
so I'm like I'm gonna take that back
but if you make I got what you mean a
lot of lot of fun stuff for differences
in the way the strokes are yeah so I
know it should be but I think in this
case because the book is pretty
geometric I know it's yeah so just for
people don't know that Martin are
talking about which is if you make the
vertical stroke mathematically the same
as the horizontal stroke optically it'll
look like the horizontal stroke is
thicker than the vertical stroke it's
just the way things work so you want to
take it and just push it in a little bit
for most things if you're trying to keep
everything like a mono stroke like what
this logo looks like then generally
speaking you'll want to keep it the same
that's the function okay all right this
is a lot tighter than I would ever take
in Photoshop is interesting how you work
so Kathy go ahead basically my process
in Photoshop is about the same as little
straight about just unlike that like a
really King sketch before I go into
Australia yeah I know that's what what
I'm going to run into right you're like
a comic book artists who gets the
pencils really really tight so that when
the inker is doing their job they don't
have to make up anything and I like that
because there's a lot that gets lost in
translation you guys know what I'm
talking about you design something yeah
now you're an illustrator going great is
what make sure that's all clear inside
yeah so now you're doing the same
process again but just an illustrator
stone yeah and it's nice it's nothing to
the grid so it's exactly what needs to
be yeah and then function was like
British
bo-zone okay so Katherine is saying
right here there's also like a small
difference between the grits and don't
strain on the grid from Photoshop right
so this pretty much but I made a mistake
enforceable right
okay so Katherine is saying loving the
process just letting you know that
people are always complaining about our
guests their microphones because we're
using $400 mics and amps and crazy
things so and we're in an isolation
booth so there will be a difference but
one day we'll get everybody a nice mic
when we're making some serious money
that way all our therapists sound as
good as we want them to sound so this is
also the same as a photo book it's
actually like snap to the grid so why
should all the same mm-hmm I always like
to create my own typography create my
own phones
yep but I guess in some case you can
also just buy one get a free one and
just try it once I just I swear I'm just
this way PDP tutorials saying hey your
process is mind blowing nice and then YC
is asking is this a recording I thought
it was real time yes mark is that good
you guys come on guys he can't work like
that fast I mean he's pretty fast you
could tell he's pretty fast but yes it's
sped up a little bit for the sake of our
audience I think
well speed us 2000% mm okay so that's
good good frame of reference I would
have said I sped it up 10% guys and
normally work percent slower mm I'm just
going to open a PDF all because like I
know how much people always like local
looks and mock-ups it should be yes
create some death I didn't go as far as
ideal the boss episode because what she
did was insane yes come on this is the
final one
you got to represent for the dudes out
there ideals
no can you have any right now okay so
this is our some variation with quality
and also vertical horizontal buckle and
some secondary color variations mmm
cymbal and some applications so this
might be like their storefront
maybe you saw a little book on shirts
like business parts and like their own
piece of wood you know makes anything
they can spray there are some lowest
rhymin on using mock-ups to show clients
all over might look at most times people
relevance like I don't want to use
that's not to do with their business
okay very good job okay so everybody
that's in the chat right now all 180
people in the chat let us know do you
prefer the original on the left side or
the new logo that marked finished on the
right side so let us know a or b ches
the original B is the revised one
regardless of whether you prefer one or
the other because at some point it
becomes really subjective I think he
solved some balancing issues and and
reducing the complexity of the the first
one while making it highly legible and I
think he found an interesting way to
show the flooring without literally
showing the flooring it's more implied
my only comment is that probably should
be bf like this and best friends for
Bryce but it's okay you know hey
whatever man you could have easily
changed the name if you wanted to okay
here we go everybody reading here oh
look at this new new new mostly new one
person says original but you know
there's always got to be one other
there's two people there B is - yes and
a bunch of them definitely a new one B
obviously duh okay B is better is a lot
of potential
my deal school okay
all right with that whose phone is that
Jonah I told you turn off your cell
phone God dangit that ambulance ringtone
okay why don't you hit mute smart is
killing all of us right now oh my god
okay you meted them okay good okay so
let's switch gears let's move on to what
Everton our brand-new logo therapist is
going to do so let me bring up
evidencing so he is working with as
local submission from Hodgdon held o vac
ROG didn't held them back I know I
butchered it sorry and the logo looks
something like this this is pretty nice
logo using futur ax as the logo type the
word mark slider and probably some
custom thing hopefully at least it looks
like that some kind of interesting s
okay real quick mark can you stop
sharing your screen yeah Marge stop
sharing please and then I'm sorry
yeah it's okay there's a joke in there
but I'm not gonna do it not kind of do
it so Everton then you can share your
screen yes by hitting that green share
button at the bottom bottom center there
you go sharing the screen all right I
guess alright okay hold on wait wait for
Jonah to say we're good to go he's like
you were you kind of like showed up one
minute before nice reven to go Everton
you're in Brazil somewhere right yeah
yeah where's how's the weather there in
app right now it's it's pretty it's
pretty hot pretty horribly near mark but
it's just normal or is it just it's you
got to go through a heatwave - no no
it's uh it's just super hot like it's
super heavy every day every year and
every day basically that's what you're
used to then yeah yeah how do you say
cool man
air-conditioning okay so good air
conditioning I thought you're gonna say
a certain kind of clothing or just it
comes naturally
okay nothing crazy like that alright
okay Jonah be ready okay so go ahead
take it away so I just want to start
saying that Marv is so prolific right oh
my god it's just so many things
happening on his screen damn I'm just
more rational okay and I just started to
ask
achtung like a couple of questions to
understand better like the whole picture
of what is siter is about so it was it
is I start up they are new guys they are
like super fresh people in the industry
and they believe in details and quality
and all the kind of stuff so they
believe they're building high quality
premium brand it's a little bit focused
on tourism right now they are developed
to own their own products their mobiles
and web applications so I asked about
the symbol and he said that they tried
to incorporate the letter S in that kind
of boat in dynamic way represent
movement action mm-hmm and any it you
were right
it's the Torah like the side of my face
and then they're thinking to be like a
master brain sometime you know like with
more sub brands and products that are
not entirely tech oriented in that way
even though they have like these big
goals for the futures about this company
but for me it kinds of it kind of I have
to choose like what I what what should i
do I should I do like the cider company
as it it is right now so I start up like
web applications mobile or should I try
to to bring it up to another level like
being like a global master brand so
that's it's something that we should
talk about brand architecture right man
perhaps it's not on my first show let's
talk about it later okay you're like hey
let me not try to kill yes the first
time on my show
all right let's get let's go yo my first
analysis about the logo was I have I
kind of have mixed feelings about the
symbol you know it's it's had these
round corners and the typeface has like
super bold and tight and geometric super
heavy so I wasn't feeling like about
startup Association I wasn't not sure
about like this premium quality either
because when I saw like logos like
Virgin Records for example they have
this signature right that's it's hand
drawing like and it's helped their
attitude and I wasn't feeling that way
on this sign hit this word mark here so
but what I liked about it it was that it
was simple legible and it's well
balanced too so let's go to my video
that I started to this is my main
structure to design logos I just love
that eight-point grid system I don't
know if the audience is familiar but
real quick it's something a video we're
not seeing the video you have to share
something else now which still CLT a
screen yet cutting back to me and
somebody pointed out why does this a
copyright 2018 yo its 2019 so I'm going
back in to change all of that just for
you guys just for quality control yeah a
little bit of QC here okay
ready already
mm-hmm okay there is so it's an
eight-point grid system and what it does
is that it's it's more like a layout to
scream it's based on pixel eyes and all
that stuff and what 88.3 does it kind of
gives me more control about the pixel I
can't I hate bro first you can spur size
as I'm working and then when I use this
this grid system
the forms it gets we have like crisp
edges
we have more consistency we have more
feeling more precision so I kind of
started to do like that so and then I
was like so let me speed up a little bit
okay okay so I started to like drawing
thinking about forms and shapes and just
to get loose whatever it comes to my
mind so I start first thing that I did
was the most dramatic OS I could
possibly remember so and from that I
went like exploring different shapes and
forms
I tried this as in a circle to just to
get the handle of it you know to get
familiar with the shapes that I have to
build and then I went explored this a
little bit oh I see you're drawing the
the s in in knocking it out of the
circle yeah yeah and then from this
study here the sketch was trying
thinking about like that switch on and
off buttons that UI has so kind of get
familiar with all the things startup
does and programming applications and
trying to get into that that environment
try different things thermo as and then
I tried to explore like different ways
to represent an ass also and then
eventually I went back to the first
option and went to explore it a little
further so we'll take that in a moment
mm-hmm so you're just yeah working on
forms right now different SS and seeing
what may or may not work for you yeah
okay so instead of sketching in
Photoshop or in paper you're sketching
very tightly using illustrator yeah okay
yeah makes sense so somebody's asking
this question radoo mirin is asking hey
future academy when it comes to
expressing a warder emotion through the
logo how can you do that without making
a complex logo I think the the question
that you're asking is setting yourself
up for failure
I don't think logos are supposed to
express communication or emotions at all
because over time when the company grows
and changes or launches different
marketing campaigns they now become
anchored to this one encapsulated idea
so you have to kind of think about the
longevity of the logo and to see how
long can live as a singular expression
so the idea is when you get into like
really high-end corporate branding that
you get paid a lot of money for it it
shouldn't be following trends it
shouldn't be too expressive it's not
supposed to illustrate anything Oh
something weird well Oh eighties video
effect okay I had to get ahead okay go
back I have to share another video okay
we're seeing it yep good you're testing
Jonah's ability right then right now
he's like glued fast okay go ahead and
play okay so it's not my screen right
yet oh okay maybe what you can do is
share your desktop and just play
whatever is on your desktop instead of
sharing
did your application because every time
you switch it it won't show it okay it
depends on how many things you have to
share and if you have a really messy
desktop to know that you guys like the
artwork behind me look at that there you
go there you go there you go okay all
right all right cool go ahead and play
okay so I ended up like finding that
that form that really sticks to me I
wasn't feeling like but I tried to to to
improve it so the way it the first video
stopped I wasn't feeling it like that
logo wasn't balanced it's to take not
refine it and a little bit confused so I
went back and make some improvements
it's the same process like shapes and
aligned to the green and like dropping
lines in getting the super tight like as
as last anchor points that I can get to
a form so and then I was satisfied with
this final version and then I went back
to to the compare so comparison so this
is what it's I ain't it up like okay so
wait do you know mm-hmm these are the
different days you've explored yeah all
sketches that I did and just to reach
that final version that I would go for
it mm-hmm right so explore a bunch of
things circle bunch of ass like
different bars different wait for the
logo and such and then here's the the
old version and here's the new version
and I was kind of like thinking about
like
oh man like IBM like so base the
Continental Airlines I kind of get gives
me that Formula One vibe you know like
that kind of movement boat and
excitement and I just went for it mmm
cool and then I did this to explore a
little bit more like how could an
identity system could works like lines
and dots and to bring luck like that
tech vibe that I would that I wanted to
achieve and I missed on the older one so
here's another video that way a lot of
people have before you move on I really
like how you've taken the elements is
you know and and did this like silver
emboss
well stamping on there is it's a nice
look it adds adds like a feeling of
luxury yeah yeah that bring that premium
quality that I talked about on the brief
mm-hmm nice so yeah and then people a
lot of times the people love mock-ups
right so a lot of times I get questions
so where did you get it where did you
get it and the trophy is that I made
them on 3d so of this process okay to
encourage others designers to do the
same thing you know yeah that's a good
word encourage more like I showed you up
when I get a smock up I made it I made
it okay okay so they're just uh what
program very designer yes
moto look so like moto super short video
just to to see how it works in a to get
people familiar with you know because a
lot of times mock-ups for me I don't
know man I I don't know I like them but
I like to control my scenes I like to
control the way I thinking about the
printing techniques and other kind of
stuff so there are strangelets different
scenes and and so on and then I enter it
so mm-hmm
I love how Brazilians say the are its
with an H sound so he hindered it how
did you hinder it yeah he entered it he
handled his business is what he did okay
beautiful I know obviously if you can do
3d and control your lighting and the
setup it's a lot more you know we've
been awesome here if you had one of
those cards like flipped in 3d and
there's like shallow depth of field like
floating in space you know above the
rest
yeah I had them I have another project
that I did that so anyway and then I was
trying to like bring bring on the table
like some some like a different kind of
type you know so we can so we can
compare to one another so - like how
does it say that to confirm that
typefaces brought to us like a very
specific mood and you know so I wanted
to bring that decider an upper case to
get that premium quality and like a
major brain going on so that's why I did
that
and it's the the older one the new one
nice job okay now everybody you get a
chance to let us know which do you
prefer the original on the left of cider
which is we'll call that a and then now
we'll call the new one done by Everton
how we handed it that will
that'd be so what do you guys prefer you
like a or B let us know your thoughts
and anything else that you want to add
to that okay good job man good job both
you guys is there anything else is there
anything else you want to share with us
every time being this is your first time
on the show
yeah I'm pretty nervous man I want to do
better next time but you're doing great
what did you say Jonah he's got some
Brazilians in the house okay you wanna
you want to welcome the Brazilians in
the house in your native Portuguese
language
go ahead there's like there's my people
Oh golly are you Cara really is a don't
ye Brasileiro wanna know the future
[Music]
beautiful all right
obrigado obrigado okay well good job oh
my goodness all right okay everybody's
like giving us our comments right now
and I'm hoping I'm hoping I'm encouraged
that this may be the new dynamic duo
between Mart and Everton to keep
bringing the fresh logo designs and next
time maybe he'll do some master branding
stuff and school all of us in that okay
you guys both did a great job I want to
thank you for doing that I need to share
my screen hold on Jonah entertain the
people for a second you're not
entertaining okay let me mirror this
there we go boom okay Matthew just
handed me a note here so go and share my
screen I just want to let everybody know
I don't know if you know this or not but
we actually are able to sustain a living
by making videos courses and kits to
support doing these videos on YouTube
it's not a lot but this is how we do it
so if you guys scroll down here on if
you go to the Academy I'm sorry
Academy dot the futurecom there's one
here called logo design it's kind of
relevant to our topic right now so for
some of you guys it might be out of
reach a $149 but we try our very best to
give you the most value per dollar just
so that we can keep doing this with you
guys and you'll get a whole bunch of
content you can check it out I just want
to let you know that something like this
exists there's my ugly face and we
design a bunch of different things with
our amazing designers Emily min and
think somebody else I can't
and and I don't know maybe Molly yes
Molly - Emily Molly and min working on
this kind of stuff so if you want to get
better at logo design I would encourage
you to do this and having said that let
me just get us out of here guys thank
you very much for doing this let me do
this okay if you are having a case of
missing out FOMO fear of missing out the
way that you guys can participate on
this is to look up the future on
Facebook where we call for entries and
submissions and one of our amazing logo
therapists might pick you that's how it
works now just keep in mind we get a lot
more submissions than we have time to do
we're human beings we have work and we
have other things to do but that's how
you do it and that's it I wanted okay
Jenna well we're both a little rusty
it's okay don't forget to Like comment
and subscribe and hit the bell
notification because of the way
YouTube's algorithm works if you don't
hit the bell you won't get notified it
won't appear in your feed like it used
to that's it for us guys thank you very
much both you guys have a great and cool
weekend I'll see you guys next time bye
everybody